D "MUZZLE" JUS
SAW THE PAPER BACK EDION
AVAIE PING.
COEAD OFIDENTIFYING THE POLITICA
SIF
ISSUES.
E OTE, THEOISE
OR, ITORSM TAKES OAN
HORRIF UNBELIEVABLY
UEEACHPT
SERVATIVESANHURCH  N.THE GUY D V
T IIN
PARTISANICWAN PC HTOTO
THT LOTS ATI
CAUSE THEY MAKE FOR GOODLE UP.
S PAY TO TY IT'S IMPORTANT
POLITICAL MIFICATIONS.
E STORON O.
LLECTIVELY, ALTS TO CORRECT AND
ERH. OIS
PEND ARE EASY TO
WAS NEARLYAINSAND ME, FO AIR DOL
THE UPROAR OF THE ART INSTITUTE
LACK.DIVERSITY.82
ARS'XPE THEY
RECEIVED AFROM T
R VERONITE ICEX VOLTQUOTE, AS CL
PARTICIPATE, IN IN
REQUIRE FAN BLT PARTICIPATE.
"THE WSTOURNAL"
ICG TH
TO BE IN THGRIPS OF ADEFEATING.
IT HAS ADOPTED THE LAND
MIDDLE CLASSTHAT IT
IN
ARE  AS TOUR GUIDES,
VEGEPATHAT BIZARLYATHET
HE HEA
UC BERKELEY HERETE
PHYSICDAD ROMPS UN AANOTHER UNI
BOTT, YO MNOTO GIVE
A E CLCA
OF COU BIGGEST RECENT ADREADY CE
ISP OV EL CULTURE WAR
NETFLIX SPECIAL "THE"ATESOUT THA
IS IT PC
Y  TRYING TO GET SE WHO S
AROUND TO THE END HEA TENDER S
FRIEND.WHPRENTTER I TBL
THM
PHOBIC JOKE?INK NEEDS TO HAVE DC
COS T EXTINGUISH
THEM A
OF TRUTH, SOME PEOPLE ARG  CCHA
.
NG FIRS OS
OO BIG THAEY'D
BE SAC EMP
IN A NOB
MET NDERST N VERING FOR THE HATN
HE LOW POLITICALE CEE THE LEFT I
TOAT AALE STINEL AD OF THEVOA M
DOWN THES
JEFFTHEY MIGHT W
D WEIGHT OST
GREACAL MOTIVATOFOS E
RVEYUE@SMERCON
CTUOR DRAGO ANSWE'L Y ATER. T I
STEPPIFRT POSITIONCAUSE
ESEAKE
CLIMATE SCIENCE BECAUSE OF THES.
S EXPLAINED HIS
SAYING QUOTE, IT BAM
TOWHWE COULDNVIT
THATCIAGAIN, LET ONE NOW.
THEIR PO MINISHESHE
BBOTPOMORE BROADLY SUCEXCLUSN OO
UBSTRUCTION CAUS BRIOTING IN CH.
AND IZIN PROCO-WRON PIECR "NEWSW
MOSTLYUIUT THECTARBLQU
NOR AN
DEALT I SEEKS TO IAS
HE'S AN ASSOATSITY OF CHICAGS OL
DRTT,  FOR BHERE.
YOU SAY ALL OFWHICH I'S NOT A P
AMERICANDES ANS WHO SUPPORT TH
SOCIETY SHOULD BE PONCEL CULTUR.
YA CLIME SCIENTIS A SPEECHT U E
PARTICULAR, IT
PLA C
H-LIKE.
WONDINE ? WANG
E  OF  YTU IN WHED RAYS ASINS RS
EXAIEAH, I AR LF NATION THAT'S .
GEINF D GO M.I.T., DIDINTENDO GS
NEVER GOING TO CUP DING MY
RAEEK,"  EBEF A GROUP
AKE THATHETRITS
ET CETERTERA.
>> YEAH. HUMAN BEINGS AS